welcome to this video playing chromis
from from Norway no name yeah i played
him a number of times sixty percent
score okay we have this sort of um
chigorin I'd like to start with Bishop
f4 this kind of a check and this is in
this opening this a this only recently
did was this against the same guy maybe
we're felt I had a good position but
then it simply it simply wasn't so great
i think i played h3 in this other game
hmm
yeah this this type of position should
always be at least them slightly better
for wide simply because of the better
central control however it's not the end
of the world like and I can play that
that's not it's not terribly bad what
he's doing the question maybe you can
take on a three-play five they're
probably not okay yeah probably probably
should recapture but this looks quite
comfortable nothing nothing terribly
exciting but not bad as we're not bad
bad either Bishop t6 maybe this one yeah
okay I probably need to take
that's a bit strange I mean how does he
justify the move really taking on f3 but
this this should be at least at least a
slight advantage of 395 I have this at
the end i have not be five most like
that okay i can also play Bishop e2 here
trying to keep the bishop pair it's
maybe better even as I'm also
threatening night b5 now it keeps more
pieces on the board the spaceship e5 is
also leading to an opposite colored
bishops which probably does not help my
cause c6 maybe night a four-night a 45
yeah c6 i think was almost forced pneus
sorry night b5 wasn't and about to about
to happen k retreat on taking it f for
Bishop e3 is also not not bad but okay I
want you don't want to give it up so
quickly this bishop and also f4 here
possible the Knights if if I exchange
the Knights the problem is is I I
exchange a piece that are one of those
pieces that does not have a stable post
this is why i'm a bit reluctant to do
that okay maybe f4 is really threatened
if I know if it's a bit a bit ugly if I
allow that okay this Bishop looks silly
but I can I can reactivate it later and
i'm playing for the quick Bishop c4 him
so Bishop c4 [ __ ] Knight f6 maybe this
this this first so that I have 95 in the
right situation white or it retreats all
the way back also possible of course key
Bishop c4 coupe seafoam and then Knight
c3
playing for Roxy seven at the end of the
line or or he takes and we should be
five rook Jack at the end I have Brooke
c7 of course this Bishop it i hope i can
i can get it back into play with f3
bishop you want something like that you
cannot have it all at least most of the
time okay probably a mistake now
probably get out of maybe Here I am you
to get out of this is check discovery
okay let's Ave rook g7 maybe
brooke dismay 37 wow really I know this
is a totally stupid looking piece check
with the with the porn on the queenside
I don't believe it
check check now you can absolutely
cannot trade routes in this position I
don't believe it rhythm okay so can i
just enter with the king i guess i can
with f5 being played so i probably
should approach those those pawns first
not take the f pawn it is the right
color of the bishop which is of course
important
yeah and two points assists too much and
who s the right did the right color very
important yeah so am I really killed
this pc on g3 but I went for I go I got
the same rank so this is probably right
but of course here brooke d 8 is just
losing out right Sharon not sure that
something else is holding but a thought
rook c8 with this idea this still looks
fairly fairly interesting because he can
check just just try to play this
position with rooks on I cannot easily
activate the king and just pushing
before here for is not working I still
have this very stupid looking P so this
has very decent chances to hold I
believe I computer points or Bishop age
42 d 8 that's a good idea maybe
hmm yeah okay but still he must do that
the the bishop endgame is just a just a
flat-out win for white okay thanks for
watching